Quería hablar un poco
del sentido común porque
a veces siento que es algo que
hemos perdido como sociedad.
Y yo no solo lo veo en Costa Rica,
yo lo veo en todos lados.
Esta es una imagen en Londres,
del absoluto molote
que sucede en mero centro.
Y voy a otras ciudades
como España, Madrid.
Me da esperanzas de que todavía
el ser humano es lo más importante,
no el automóvil, no la máquina, sino que
nosotros somos lo más importante.
Por dicha tenemos estos
ejemplos que podemos pensar.
Pero para mí, mi pasión,
mi corazón está en Costa Rica,
yo no puedo dejar de pensar en mi país.
Sinceramente trato de ver como hago
para hacer proyectos acá, a toda costa.
Me acuerdo, yo he ido mucho
a Limón y me acuerdo
de estas casas de madera
que están en pilotes
y ahora las casas nuevas
las están construyendo
en zonas de inundaciones
pegadas al piso, ¿verdad?
¿En dónde hubo un cambio?
¿Qué pasó?
¿En dónde perdimos el sentido común?
A tal punto que hasta nuestra
propia supervivencia está en riesgo.
Quiero enseñarles algunos ejemplos
de cosas que hemos hecho,
que estamos trabajando en Londres
con el arquitecto Richard Rogers,
del cual soy asociado.
Este es un complejo en Inglaterra,
ese es el tipo de vivienda
de interés social que se
ha generado en los años 80,
y nosotros queríamos participar
con los mismos presupuestos
de vivienda de interés social
a ver que podíamos hacer nosotros.
Cómo podíamos humanizar esto
que es tan lúgubre,
ventanitas chiquititas,
espacios completamente inhumanos.
Nosotros empezamos a generar
este tipo de arquitectura,
con el mismo presupuesto.
Estas casas están construidas
con el mismo material
que se hacen las mesas de McDonalds,
es un material que se llama "Trespa"
y se le da una
individualidad a cada persona,
cada persona ahora tiene un lugar
que tiene aire y ventilación natural,
iluminación natural,
no tiene que prender la luz.
El sentido común, lo más obvio,
lo que debería ser desde un principio.
Y usando los mismos presupuestos,
o sea hubo que ver
como se hacía con el material
más barato y que fuera excelente.
Para nosotros ahora es un orgullo
que la gente ahora quiera vivir ahí,
que esté orgullosa de su hogar,
y que la gente quiera venir.
Ahora más bien, ahora valen más plata
y ya no son viviendas de ese tipo.
El aeropuerto de Barajas es un aeropuerto
que se terminó hace unos años.
Esto es lo que nosotros
sabemos que es un aeropuerto,
un lugar apiñado,
lleno de gente, sin ventilación.
Y sin iluminación natural.
Para nosotros es importante
que cuando uno esté agarrando
las maletas le esté pegando
el sol en la piel,
tal vez es lo que yo llevo
a esta compañía, no sé.
Pero para mí es importante
tener esa conexión con el exterior,
no estar en esta máquina
completamente inhumana.
Para nosotros al humanizar el espacio,
con iluminaciones naturales
se bajan costos cuando
uno le dice al cliente:
"Vas a tener que pagar menos
electricidad y vamos a usar
el mismo presupuesto que
en cualquier otro aeropuerto,
no es que vamos a gastar más plata".
No es que los arquitectos estamos
aquí para despilfarrar con cosas lindas,
que con los mismos
presupuestos podemos hacer
exactamente lo mismo y hasta mejor.
El Guys and Saint Thomas Hospital
en Inglaterra también,
es un hospital que es esto,
es un absoluto bunker.
Imagínese estar ahí con un
pariente sufriendo, es horroroso,
uno no sabe ni cual piso es cual,
es de concreto todo.
Nosotros empezamos
a pensar en esta idea:
¿Cómo hacemos edificios
en altura que sean humanos?
Digamos, uno ve el edificio
y uno no sabe ni en que piso está.
Pero ¿cómo hace uno para
humanizar el espacio?
Empezamos a hacer villas en el aire.
Por ejemplo, cada una de
las villas es, por ejemplo:
quimioterapia, radioterapia,
es un espacio para
la rehabilitación
del cáncer y consejería.
Dijimos, tal vez los tres pisos sean
un espacio lo suficientemente humano,
ya después de ahí se empieza
a hacer una mole de concreto,
el edificio empieza a expresar
por afuera lo que está pasando adentro.
Espacios en terceras alturas
y empieza a decir cada uno
de estos espacios es "algo",
se entiende desde afuera, es legible.
Para nosotros era importante
apartarnos del paradigma
de que un hospital es "esto",
un espacio horrible
donde uno nada más transita
y no sabe ni dónde está
el norte, ¿verdad?
Nosotros queríamos pensar que
el espacio interior de un hospital
o de un centro de rehabilitación
podía ser mejor.
-- No está la imagen...
no importa, seguimos --
Prototipo de vivienda vertical,
entonces para mí era importante...
Está bien, estamos afuera,
practicando y haciendo lo mejor posible
por los demás, queríamos ver
cómo podíamos hacer algo
en Costa Rica, cómo podíamos empezar
a proponer cosas, ¿qué hacemos?
Empezamos a inventarnos,
empezamos a buscar clientes.
Bueno, uno de estos es el prototipo
de vivienda vertical para San José.
Nosotros sabemos que esto
es lo que más o menos
se está empezando a dar en San José,
unas cajas de concreto
con unos balconcitos que nadie usa,
en donde se pone la basura
o la bicicleta, si es que
alguien usa la bicicleta.
Nosotros pensamos que
lo mejor que podíamos hacer
era utilizar el mismo presupuesto
que estos edificios,
no podíamos empezar a jugar de locos
porque no se hace,
simple y sencillamente.
¿Cómo hacemos para
reconfigurar los mismos espacios
de una edificación como esa
en una edificación mejor?
Entonces en este lado es una planta
de un edificio tradicional,
hay un núcleo.
Todo el núcleo es en negro, el azul es
la circulación y después los espacios,
hay cuatro puertas, uno no sabe
ni en donde está y unos balconcitos.
Nosotros decimos
¿por qué no usamos ese núcleo
y mezclamos la circulación
en azul con un balcón,
antes de entrar a la habitación?
O sea, entrar por medio
de una terraza.
Nosotros sabemos
muy bien lo que es eso,
hemos vivido así
durante muchísimos años.
Entramos por una terraza llena
de verde, llena de vegetación,
nos encanta estar en
comunicación con el exterior.
¿Cómo hacemos para llevar
la tipología de la casa de campo
que nosotros añoramos tanto?
Y por eso es que nos vamos
a vivir afuera de San José
y andamos una hora y media en
un automóvil para llegar al centro.
¿Por qué no vivimos en el centro
y no tenemos que andar en el carro?
Pero claro, queremos vivir en armonía
con la naturaleza
en nuestro campo, cómodos.
Bueno, apiñemos un montón
de casas, una encima de otra.
El resultado de esto, es este...
bueno, queríamos también
integrar un jardín.
Un jardín vertical, un elemento
que diera de comer
también a los habitantes
de este edificio.
Esta es la tipología,
realmente aquí en este ejemplo
se ven cuatro módulos
pero se pueden poner
un módulo o dos módulos.
Realmente es una manera
de pensar que se puede aplicar
en muchas propiedades pero
la idea es que en este balcón
todo el mundo tuviera
una relación con la calle,
que todo el mundo tenga
esta vegetación en frente
y que sea un filtro hacia el exterior.
Que haya comercio,
que haya mezcla de usos.
Que no solo sea: "Yo voy a mi casa
y después tengo que ir a trabajar
quién sabe dónde...
Tal vez yo puedo comer aquí;
tal vez yo puedo vivir aquí,
trabajar aquí, puedo hacer de todo".
Esta es la planta de distribución,
uno llega al elevador,
y después llega por
esta terraza al interior.
Obviamente la circulación
se convirtió en terraza
y por ende, los mismos
espacios de circulación
ya no son circulación,
ya es otra cosa.
Queríamos pasar de esto,
que es espantoso, a esto, tal vez.
Esto se puede hacer
en nuestras latitudes.
¿Por qué nosotros no jugamos
con lo que ya tenemos?
¿Por qué no vivimos
la vida que queremos vivir?
¿Cómo hacemos
para cambiar el paradigma
con los mismos presupuestos
y las mismas ideas?
La tecnología tiene que tener sentido,
y en este edificio
tenía que ser sostenible
desde todo punto de vista.
Ahí vemos edificaciones como estas
que tienen los más altos grados
de certificaciones ecológicas,
que se le ponen solamente
unos paneles fotovoltaicos
a la típica caja horrorosa
con un montón de escritorios,
¿quién quiere estar ahí?
Nosotros no creemos que la tecnología
se tenga que usar de esta manera,
más bien nosotros creemos en la tecnología
para tratar de hacer edificaciones
que no gasten y que sean cómodas
y que no se prenda la luz,
que la temperatura sea cómoda,
que hayan ventilaciones naturales
y que no haya que usar la tecnología.
La tecnología se utiliza antes
y no como un remedio, no un maquillaje.
Para nosotros es importante
el sentido común.
Usar la tecnología para lo que es.
Bueno, yo quería llegar ahora
a proyectos ya concretos,
yo sé que no he hecho
mucho aquí en Costa Rica
pero aquí estamos
haciendo cada vez más.
Este proyecto es de unos
amigos míos, que, bueno,
cuando se vino la recesión uno
de ellos se quedó sin trabajo,
tenía una deuda muy grande,
vivía en una casa con un montón
de cuartos y de todo, y estaban
un poco ahogados, y tenían una propiedad.
Yo les dije: "¿Y por qué
no se van a vivir a allá,
a las afueras de San José,
y viven en un "huevito",
viven así en algo chiquitito,
¿qué importa?"
"Uds. ocupan todo los cuartos
de visita, el cuarto de televisión,
todo ese montón de cosas.
Al final, ¿eso qué?
¿Los hace felices estar hasta el cuello?
¿Por qué no nada más están tranquilos
y viven en algo más humilde,
entre comillas?
Hagamos algo razonable.
Ellos dijeron:
"Bueno hagamos la casa del guarda
en un futuro hacemos
el "Chozómetro", ¿verdad?"
Entonces dijeron: "Bueno, está bien,
hagamos la casa del guarda".
Entonces agarramos dos contenedores,
los separamos,
agarramos los lados del contenedor
y los pusimos como un techo
en el centro, o sea, reconfiguramos
el material que ya existía,
sin comprar mucho más,
para hacer un espacio cómodo
en donde circulara
el aire naturalmente,
donde se bloqueara el sol
y en donde se sintiera más amplio.
Nadie quiere vivir en una lata
de atún, sinceramente.
Este es el espacio, muy sencillo:
sala, comedor, cocina
en un solo espacio y la cama.
Llegaron los contenedores,
estaban destartalados,
herrumbrados, todo lo que
Uds. quieran. Espantosos.
Yo con miedo: "Esto no va a servir,
¿qué estoy haciendo?
Estoy embarcando a la gente".
Pero requiere de gente
con visión también.
No es que yo sea el que propone,
tiene que ser el cliente también,
conmigo, que nos tiremos
al agua y a ver qué sale.
Este es el producto, el producto
es una casa ya para ellos
de la cual no se quieren mover ahí
quieren vivir el resto de sus vidas.
Y esta es su sala de afuera,
le van a poner un "deck", ahí en frente,
todavía no tienen la platita.
Yo creo que tal vez
ya se lo pusieron, no sé.
Realmente es bastante cómoda,
realmente es un espacio digno de vivir.
Yo viviría ahí, yo no crearía nada
en lo cual no viviría yo mismo.
Ellos están muy contentos,
la ventilación,
o sea, dicen que nunca han tenido
que prender el aire acondicionado.
Es en Ciudad Colón, que todos sabemos
que en esta época es un horno.
El espacio es muy agradable,
se ve el atardecer, se ve el amanecer.
Para mí esta imagen refleja mucho,
la tomó Andrés García Lagner.
Pero esa sensación de que ellos
están felices ahí con su perro
viendo el atardecer,
están contentos, no tienen deudas,
están felices, van a ir
a visitarme a Londres...
¡El mundo cambió completamente
con esta caja de latas!
(Aplausos)
Realmente para mí lo
más importante era esto,
que esta casa de aquí no sabíamos
en cuanto iba a salir,
en serio no sabíamos
y salió más barata que una casa
en Cinchona de USD 46 000.
Esta salió en USD 40 000.
Completamente lista, con jacuzzi,
aire acondicionado,
todos los lujos,
todo lo que Uds. quieran.
Claro, se ve como un contenedor
desde fuera, pero estamos trabajando
ahora en casas que sean estéticas
desde afuera también, porque la gente...
"Hey, yo no quiero ponerle
contenedores a todo el mundo".
(Risas) -- Aquí supuestamente
tenía que poner una imagen,
pero realmente veamos
estas imágenes de adentro --
Esta es una imagen ahora
de lo que estamos generando,
para una casa de tres cuartos
hecha con cuatro contenedores,
dos encima de dos.
Sala, comedor, cocina,
circulaciones arriba, los cuartos,
o sea, una casa cómoda,
esta casa está siendo...
Bueno, la primera casa,
la que vieron de contenedores explotó.
Miles de personas me contactan
diariamente alrededor del mundo.
Se están construyendo
en Australia, en todos lados.
Espectacular, no lo puedo creer,
hasta en África,
ahora me han contactado
organizaciones no gubernamentales
en varios países que quieren
usarla como prototipo.
Claro, el interior
va a ser diferente,
pero es el prototipo,
la idea, el concepto.
Como se manipuló el material
de manera creativa.
Yo quiero terminar la charla
con este proyecto
que fue para mí, el inicio de todo,
desde que estoy pequeño realmente...
tal vez yo quería ser arquitecto
para poder darle
una casa a mi madre
que no la pasó bien.
Cuando yo era niño, pues...
no teníamos mucho dinero
y ella más adelante se fue a construir
este hogar, en Playa Avellana,
se la hizo a partir de palos,
latas de zinc, de Sarán,
y ella vivía contenta ahí.
Sí vivía con miedo, sinceramente,
de que viniera alguien...
pero, estaba como a la intemperie.
Y yo como hijo, estudiando en los Estados Unidos,
en las mejores universidades.
"¿Yo que estoy haciendo aquí?
¿De qué voy a hacer mi tesis?
¿Voy a hacer así este... el súper "Chozómetro"
o una cosa inventada?"
"No, mientras mi mamá tiene una necesidad".
Entonces utilicé mi proyecto de tesis
para diseñarle una casa a mi madre.
Y me gustaría leerles un cuento
que es realmente la inspiración
de cómo fue que la diseñé,
por qué la diseñé.
Benjamín: ¿Les parece?
Audiencia: ¡Sí!
OK, pura vida.
"Ella se levanta cuando
la luna va desapareciendo.
El gran sonido de los grillos le recuerda
que está rodeada por el bosque.
El calor del sol naciente
se filtra por entre las hojas
y calienta los pisos de madera.
Ella sabe que ya es tiempo
de hacer el pan.
El sonido de los grillos ha cambiado
por el canto de los pájaros.
La estufa calienta el aire
y el olor se disipa
por cada hendija hacia el bosque.
Mi mamá va afuera, a ducharse
con el agua del tanque de agua
y repentinamente una pequeña
lluvia se mezcla con su agua,
ella recorre la casa a secarse
con el calor de la estufa.
Yo me levanto y me doy cuenta
de que ya amaneció,
el sol está afuera
y hay pan fresco en la mesa.
Puedo ver que mamá está sembrando
una planta de aloe en su sala.
De alguna manera ella sabe cuál
es el mejor lugar para que crezca.
Los rayos del sol golpean el techo
de zinc, ella abre todas las puertas,
cedazos y ventanas y el viento empieza
a golpear sus sábanas hindúes.
También puedo ver las sábanas
recién lavadas que cuelgan
desde dos grandes árboles
que le dan sombra a la casa.
El viento sopla las hojas
y las trae hacia la casa.
Mamá siempre está limpiando
pero nunca nada está limpio.
No hay mucho que hacer,
pero ella siempre se mantiene ocupada
con su artesanía, libros
de corte izquierdista, un puro
y una que otra llamada telefónica.
Ella se mueve por toda la casa
tratando de encontrar una mejor señal.
Ella ha encontrado el mejor
lugar para hablar por celular
entre la puerta principal
y el árbol, ahí ella ha puesto
una roca en la que
se puede sentar por horas.
Mi mamá me quiere llevar
a la playa pero puedo ver
que ella está preocupada
de dejar sola la casa.
Ella esconde algunas
de sus posesiones más preciadas,
los libros, las fotos y los puros.
Ella luego pone una rama
en frente de la entrada,
enciende el radio y deja
la puerta bien abierta.
Luego ella grita:
"¡Adiós, nos vemos luego!",
como si todavía hubiera
alguien en la casa.
A mí me parece como si ella
estuviera diciendo adiós a la casa
y la casa a su vez murmura entre
el bosque mientras nos alejamos,
cada vez más y más lejos del radio.
Caminamos por el bosque
hasta la calle de piedra
que luego nos lleva a la playa.
Mi mamá va a bañarse en el mar
y luego de un rato se sienta
a la par mía para ver el atardecer.
Ella está completamente deslumbrada
aunque lo ha visto cientos de veces.
Ella me dice que deberíamos
volver a la casa para agarrar
los últimos rayos de sol
que nos guíen en el camino.
Empezamos a oír el radio más y más fuerte
mientras nos acercamos a la casa.
La luz del sol va desapareciendo y muy pronto
el bosque va a estar iluminado por la luna.
Ella tiene miedo de que la oscuridad
traiga a algún intruso a molestarnos.
Las candelas proveen una luz cambiante
mientras ella toca la guitarra
y ella prepara una cena rápida
que es difícil de comer por la falta de luz.
La luz de la luna entra en la casa
y yo sé que ella pronto se va a ir a dormir.
Ella ha puesto su cama
en una esquina de la casa
para tener una vista directa de
la luna mientras se va a dormir.
Ella se lava la cara y envuelve
su cuerpo con paños mojados
que le bajan la temperatura.
Puedo ver que la vista de
la luna la deslumbra cada noche
y que el sonido de los grillos
la pone a dormir,
de vez en cuando ella se despierta
en alerta por el sonido
de sus alarmas naturales.
La única cosa que le da arrullo
es la vista iluminada de la luna
moviéndose entre las ramas
de los árboles". Entonces...
(Aplausos)
Ya ella había encontrado su casa,
¿qué le iba a dar yo?
Entonces al final, pues...
realmente yo le di la luna.
Realmente yo diseñé una casa
en donde yo le enmarcaba la luna
mientras ella se iba a dormir.
Y que ella supiera que aunque
yo estuviera donde sea que esté,
soy yo el que le estoy
regalando esa luna.
Y que mientras ella se va a dormir,
yo me acuerdo de ella,
y ella se acuerda de mí.
La arquitectura es más
que solo cumplir una función
de tener un hogar donde no se moje,
donde esté contenta
o donde pase la brisa y donde
no tenga aire acondicionado.
Es más que eso,
es más que sentido común.
La primera vez que vimos
la casa, que vimos la luna
-- Voy a devolverme --
por medio de este cono que
se abre hacia el cielo,
fue impresionante, yo no creía
que iba a servir tampoco.
Fue la primera vez
que creí que, tal vez...
(Risas) Que algo de lo
que yo hago tiene valor
y que realmente no es solamente
sentido común, era mucho más.
Era el amor, darle algo a alguien,
dar lo que realmente
quieren las demás personas.
Sobre todo una madre, ¿verdad?
Todos los materiales que Uds.
ven acá son de la casa vieja.
La casa tiene el techo de zinc de
la casa vieja, la madera de la casa vieja,
el bambú fue de una finca que
fue regalado... todo.
Yo construí la casa yo mismo,
la tuve que hacer en módulos
porque realmente no tenía
la plata para hacerlo
estaba en Londres haciendo platita.
Hicimos primero un módulo,
después hicimos el otro y ahora me llaman,
me escriben de todas partes del mundo,
que quieren hacer hoteles
con estos módulos,
quieren replicarlos por todos lados.
Veo que también hay una
replicabilidad del proyecto.
Pero para mí lo más importante era esto,
generarle un bosque interno,
que ella pudiera estar segura.
Este asunto de la seguridad
en Costa Rica es importante.
Una señora sola ahí en
el bosque, que pudiera estar
adentro de su casa
y que estuviera segura.
Realmente en vez de bambú
hay unas barras de metal
y entra la luz como si fuera
el bosque y era importante
que ella se sintiera segura,
que ella estuviera feliz
y que al mismo tiempo no entraran
los mosquitos, todas esas cosas.
Por supuesto, sí, que no se meta
la lluvia, que no entren los mosquitos.
Sí está bien pero realmente esa sensación
de estar dentro de un bosque,
de ver hacia arriba
y ver iluminado el bambú
como si fueran hojas de los árboles.
Y tratando de ver como se inspira
uno en la naturaleza de mi país
para brindarle algo más a la arquitectura
que sea más que solo la función.
Para mí es un orgullo haber participado
en el World Architecture Festival
en el año 2010.
En el año 2009 mi jefe,
Richard Rogers, un arquitecto
que hizo el museo Pompidou y bueno,
proyectos muy grandes,
ganó el premio y en el 2010
lo gané yo a los 30 años,
y con esta casita en Costa Rica
en contra de todos los pronósticos.
(Aplausos)
Yo quería decirles que seguimos trabajando,
tenemos más proyectos
pero que esto ganó el premio
a la mejor casa del mundo,
y todo esto no porque
yo estaba buscando la fama
sino porque realmente había una
necesidad de darle algo al prójimo.
Después de que yo le hice la casa
a mi mamá, de hecho yo dije:
"Nunca yo voy a poder amar a nadie
de esa forma, es mi mamá".
Pero después salió el de los contenedores
y ahora están saliendo
otras cosas y siento que sí
puedo brindar a mi país eso
y que eso es reconocido
internacionalmente.
Y que si hacemos las
cosas bien, si creemos que
estamos ayudando a los demás
otras personas lo van a reconocer,
y si no lo reconocen, ¿qué importa?
Nosotros lo sabemos y nos vamos
a dormir en la noche
sabiendo que estamos haciendo
lo mejor que podemos.
Se los aseguro que eso
va a ser espectacular,
que tenemos los recursos para hacerlo
con solo el sentido común,
no importa que no tengamos las
tecnologías más grandes, ¡no importa!
Enfoquémonos en lo que sí tenemos,
tenemos una belleza natural,
tenemos ingenio, creatividad,
tenemos las ganas.
Enfoquémonos nada más en hacer
las cosas bien hechas
para los demás y no para nosotros mismos.
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado aquí.
(Aplausos)